speaking of bad guys Joe Biden got asked
they invite I mean this is so incredible
they invited a bunch of tick-tock
influencers that that's a thing they
invited a bunch of tick-tock influencers
oh and I should tell you guys I am not
on Tick Tock I'm sure I'm being
impersonated on Tick Tock I am not on
Tick Tock I will never get on Tick Tock
I've had a million offers for a lot of
money to get on Tick Tock and do all
sorts of stuff on Tick Tock it is it is
a weapon of the Chinese government that
uses our data against us it steals
Americans data it also shows American
children all of this crazy gender stuff
and woke nonsense while in China if
you're on Tick Tock it shows kids how to
do math and it shows them all sorts of
interesting things about engineering and
Science and more it is it is
infiltrating our country so anyway I'm
not going to get on there but a bunch of
tick-tock influencers were invited to
the White House and started asking Joe
Biden some very important questions like
uh could we silence Elon Musk
um Mr President do you think Elon Musk
is a threat to U.S national security and
should the U.S and with the tools you
have investigate his joint acquisition
of Twitter with foreign governments
which include the Saudis
I think that
Elon musk's
cooperation and or
technical
relationships with other countries
uh
is worthy of being looked at
whether or not he is doing anything
inappropriate I'm not suggesting that
I'm suggesting that it works worse being
looked at and uh
um and but that's all I'll say
there's a lot of ways uh all right
all right so let's put aside the the
stammering and the slurring and
all that let's put that aside for a
second
um he doesn't know that elon's up to no
good but we should look into it you know
I'm pretty sure one thing they can do
when they start looking is find
something they'll always find a way to
find something it's odd because I don't
think he was very interested in the
United States government looking into uh
Hunter Biden's laptop uh and any of
Hunter Biden's business dealings with
Ukrainian energy companies that was not
something that was worthy of government
looking into now you've got a guy that's
fighting for free speech the same guy
who's sending us to Mars said hey I'm
going to also solve some problems down
here I'm going to open up the major
communications platform on Earth Twitter
to more and more people I'm going to let
more and more things be said okay uh and
now we should look into him what's also
interesting about that is Joe Biden does
not get any questions off the cuff so
they planted that Tick-Tock influencer
and they gave him that question just
absolutely ridiculous